I'm very, very excited about these two recipes today.
So keep you fueled through DIY week.
So shall we kick it off?
So the first recipe we have
are Salted Peanut Butter Cookies.
Now this recipe is actually from
one of my personal favorite bakeries called Ovenly
and they're based in Brooklyn, New York
that just makes ridiculously good dessert.
We're going to feature them
in our Small Business Gift Guide.
Oh my God. That's amazing.
They're really, really inspiring and tremendous.
So let's get started.
So first ingredient up,
we have here a cup and three quarters of light brown sugar
and we're just going to whisk in really quickly two eggs.
So that's two ingredients we're whisking away,
we're whisking away and then-
I didn't even believe you
when you wrote out the ingredient list for me.
Literally five ingredients.
That's it.
One of them being the salt topping at the end.
Yes, exactly.
Third ingredient, half a teaspoon of vanilla.
That's so delicious.
So we're just going to keep on going over here.
And then the fourth ingredient
is the peanut butter, of course.
One bowl, one of my favorites.
One bowl, which is so good.
Okay, so what you're looking for
is that the batter is fully combined.
So you don't have streaks of peanut butter
or egg or sugar anywhere.
So that looks pretty, pretty good.
And you can actually start forming right here
but what they actually recommend is freezing the dough
for just 15 minutes.
Yep. I always remember that step.
Yeah. Basically when you chill the dough,
it helps you scoop out the cookies a little easier.
And here we have a sheet pan
lined with a little parchment paper
that just makes cleanup a little easier.
And I'm just going to start scooping these out
just like that.
Really nice and easy.
And they're not going to spread to tremendous amount
so you don't have to space them out like crazy.
And before you bake them,
you're going to sprinkle a little bit
of that crunchy sea salt.
So while I'm scooping this out,
Drew, do you want to get us started
on your recipe over there?
All right.
So for your main,
now that we've tackled dessert
and you can actually prepare this
while the cookies are baking.
Yeah, absolutely.
Okay, I want to make you my favorite.
It's called the Cali tartine
and what it is is it's a delicious open-faced sandwich
and it's about as easy to make as anything you've ever done.
I'm going for a whole wheat toast today with cream cheese.
Now, I usually like to use my cream cheese
as a way to add here some of the looser products.
So I'm going to use some lettuce there
because that's sort of the trickiest to stay on.
And then I'm also going to add my tomato.
Now, one tip that I have about tomatoes
is that I like to salt them
so that you really get a nice flavor out of the tomato.
You can even put a little pepper on there.
And then I'm going to add some cucumbers on there.
It's such a fresh sandwich.
I really like, it has all this crunch and texture
and then with the layers of the different flavors
with the lemon and stuff.
It's just really, really lovely.
Well, you actually gave me the idea
to top it off with the lemon.
That wasn't something that I had ever really thought of.
So you can go at the end and do a little lemon squeeze.
Now, what I love about this sandwich so much
is Pilar is right.
You can really definitely have a choose your own adventure.
I always think that you need a creamy base on that bread
but an alternative is avocado.
Another alternative is a Tofutti,
a cream cheese that's actually not dairy
which is going to be a lot less fattening.
Let's face it.
Another thing you can do is I love this brand Base Culture
because it's a paleo bread and it's completely grain-free.
So you can actually make the sandwich so dietetic
that it's like eating air,
or you can layer it
and be a little more indulgent if you want.
But either way,
it's so simple and so easy and just like that,
you can eat it with a nice little napkin
on a beautiful little plate and a fork and knife.
And you instantly have this
gorgeous restaurant-quality sandwich.
Okay, so I'm going to pop these in the oven
350 degrees for 20 minutes.
350 for 20.
And you want to rotate them halfway through, basically.
That's right.
The freezer detail and the rotating halfway through
were always steps I could be like,
"Do not forget. Do not forget those steps."
All right.
Shall we sandwich? Shall we cookie?
Yes, first of all, I'm cookie-ing
because let's face it C is for cookie.
Cookies for me!
They taste like peanut butter.
And with the salt on top, I mean, I'm sold.
Ovenly. Pilar-
Ovenly, we love you.
We love you so much.
They are the best peanut butter cookies.
I would love, as a social experiment,
for you to write into thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
and tell us what you think of this recipe.
They're the best cookies ever.
I love it. We're going to do dessert first.
And now, we sandwich.
I couldn't resist.
Oh, well.
Hmm.
This probably isn't going to sound like
the right description,
but I just feel like I ate an entire produce section
in the best, most delicious way ever.
It's it's really, really delicious.
And sometimes just making yourself a meal like this
is such a gift to yourself.
(applause)
Thank you for having me, Drew.
Pilar, I love you so much.